yeah hello and welcome to this video
currying the game between worked and
nollie goat y el asesor canada yeah an
opening then I know what hello something
about you got the Dominion with f3 and
gnarly gold actually place the line that
I had recommended in my division Indian
book in fact I mean it's quite funny
that some publications on the news oh
that have been released them recently
have exactly the same line somehow
different authors my gang Gustav's on
the cross Lucian grade or German German
GM's and me we all came to the
conclusion that this is a good line for
Black Sea file ok let's see c5 white
goes d5 like castles Dwight doors inform
this whole line with f3 is a very
principled approach why just says okay
and the main a development of my pieces
to get this big center going and I think
that it's basically mandatory now for
black to do something against the center
and he's got more than one option one
idea is to play be five in this position
what you can and start also with d6 in
the game canali gold starts with d six
again v5 is also a possible variation
here and there are a couple of a couple
of options this is the most principled
reply after which there are ya crazy
complications but I can move the night
can you take on d5 the movie 6 rupees is
a bit more conservative is not the right
word but it avoids some extremely messy
positions but just to get into other
positions that are also sharp you can
never really play something and slowish
let's say
after you've went 45 1992 I want to say
thank GD too but okay only one light can
go there and now there is b5 again yeah
so this b5 push black um place to attack
the white center this is absolutely
making sense we have to be perfectly
clear that white grabbing a pawn is too
dangerous and white could try to play
some panic lab after d5 Lex compensation
for the pawn is absolutely outstanding I
have to say that see that this condo is
strong and the whole wide position is
uncoordinated is far behind in
development and especially the dark
squares like whenever you play it for
every your dark squares a problem d 4 f
43 they're all can be weak so taking the
pawn is no option right here um usually
goes for the move of the night only 29 f
for me what's the most common option
there and there's the thing is that the
movie 5 isn't all that fantastic why can
just drop back and after that we get
this back now and it's quite happy that
the position has closed so after this
the most common option nowadays is from
black to take on d5 or play the move a 6
i've analyzed both in my book and i
think black is ok he's got this liminal
benoni structure that is quite
interesting like this kind of structure
this also has been tested in top-level
chefs bite Apollo for example so it's a
it's a very playable line form like in
the game in the white player quirks
Clayton ig3 certainly also possible
however here there is less pressure on
these six
lateral at four here always put some
pressure on e6 and here you see a
difference like captured and play the
Queen 85 queen 85 is probably not that
great bishop a6 seems to be stronger and
here we see a difference with a nylon f4
this pawn would hang and there's like
take on a six take on take on a sixth
agony six light on g 3 is less
aggressive I think this is what black
should play here in this position after
the capture I believe like it can be
quite satisfied for example white can
cancel yeah and here black has to decide
how he wants to continue it's a question
now sexy for a lot can be interesting
see form gives the night a good square
on c5 I think this is better than the
move Queen 85 Queen a five loops
perfectly normal but in fact can be met
with a very strong reply that the white
player cooked here also played you have
to see that I'm sorry you have to see
that white and does not any caps on
let's let me do it like that he canceled
is a very strong rule you have to see
that white also could have just paid
Bishop b2 but this is not so great it
covers this reliably but after Bishop a
six this is not bad for black at all man
what is some who I supposed to do here
like taking now I cannot cancel just
ignoring the thread on my own xiii is
just a nice way to play it just gives
like this opportunity to take on c3
twice in fact I believe black shouldn't
actually take you should still play Bush
the basics and this is probably okay for
him yeah for example after the capture
black cannot be in bad shape him yeah
why he tries to do something here like
this test is repeated now you can argue
that life maybe have
guided by the structure but nothing
serious going on blackout mmm decided to
yeah basically don't believe white and
grab this pond it's a very
understandable decision it looks like a
very strong move actually like it's
attacking the rook and the bishop but
white played a really great sacrifice
here with this porn sex and actually
followed up with putting the rook here
yes or for the taking interestingly
enough taking this leads to a very nice
position for white it wasn't played by
the way but then that lets show yes like
here we should be three and now look at
the Queen if it goes to e5 and four
traps the Queen I mean like is a rope up
at the moment so the game continues in
white why should win here but still it's
not like Queen down I'm best is to get
of course a group here so the then white
is a is a porn down just by pure
counting but look at the position more
closely here white is better what is
black supposed to do it would absolutely
love to take here but we see that in the
sequence the loop here is impossible to
keep I mean mechanically and there is a
tactic this is a tactic the Queen takes
bishop a6 check but why not take this
and one thing that's very important the
night here is ready to jump to air fire
it's really interesting if black grabs
the hook and then this position here in
this position yeah why being a pawn down
is actually very favorable for him note
that five blocking everything this is
actually the most logical looking
we are to block things and then try to
consolidate this is legless Bishop g5
which is also been a problem for black
you cannot move the night if you cover
it 9x5 attacks this and this is not
covered then you cannot cover that
anymore yeah like you root b 8 i'm sorry
one single here something like that it's
not funny at all if you try to cover it
if way a five white has tremendous play
for this pawn he's just better so black
now had a really important choice to
make and he played it correctly he
traded Queens only three wide still has
a very good position that was the big
trap was really nicely played that why
turn basically baited dragon taking on
c3 and white is better than yam black
shouldn't have taken as we manner as we
mentioned shouldn't have taken in the
first place and trebuchet basics okay so
now the Queen was saturated and white
took with a porn of course opening up
their farm and again we can count why
does the pawn down but he has tremendous
play for it like now to Conde five
understand them on the serum i think ii
five just to put it into adam put into
perspective Bishop g5 is against wrong
another night now moves this one is
winning or this alternatively looks
quite bad yeah this is probably a
logical move why is recaptured with the
spawn and group the eight also good and
prophylactic recovering the porn as it
will be attacked anyway so now why play
Bishop f4 yeah how to
one that looks good and now aged six
also a sensible move preventing any
doing any pins giving some room for
black skin note that it was difficult to
actually make another or a different
move it's very difficult this position
you're completely blocks them yeah here
White has a couple of options and first
I didn't like the most late in the game
at all but looking at this a little bit
more closely I think it is actually ok I
still probably wouldn't have played it
in the game night afore misplayed and
when I dislike is that this pawn
structure here is so static and tight
white had a different idea it's not
making its aesthetic but I still think I
would rather prefer to to not offer any
trades and try to improve the root
position a little bit more something
like Ruby one or look a Jew just to have
different options double here on the
e-file the computer gives h3 as a move
which is a little bit too sophisticated
for me I like those root moves yes
trying to be flexible when white has
excellent compensation for the point
anyway but I think this is a bit more
testing than 94 but this is not as bad
as I thought originally thought this
just a bad idea but it it is not that
straightforward here white has a choice
again he can play what he did in the
game for thing matters or try to improve
the situation the computer lives again
move like a ch3 it's not a bad idea by
the way to cover this square it still
looks a little bit strange I think I
would have rather prefer one of those
moves to offer double on the 8th files
now it's possible what definitely has
compensation in the game he played in
five the direct solution the brutal
solution yeah okay um black hands to
take it and the bishop capture that was
the idea in the game black took the
suspicion that was not the only move
that came into consideration funny
enough the surprising move Bishop a 6
i'm not sure the day I think it's
surprising and what's interesting in
this position like has to mostly
consider this one after Knight takes
rook takes D takes d5 the most likely
outcome is a drawn yet those pawns were
probably for all of them there was one
one scenario what white can take here
first and then take on a six this is
equal material and again I think the
most common scenario is probably a draw
black took this however can be six check
King h8 and we should be five that was
wife's idea maybe it didn't actually
anticipate the 496 was possible i'm not
sure and 96 is the only move now
otherwise wife will pick up the whole
look they're 18 so rather once a given
night no look takes it would be eight
yeah now a very sharp situation why does
a pawn down but this is not so relevant
the main thing is what about this pawn
is that how strong is that pawn & ganna
quite started correctly by taking here
we have to note that if black now would
have taken the pawn
no of course not this one this would
have happened and this is a very unlucky
spot where it Rupe g6 look FX were in
the house is it will get six of them
it's just a funny movie making use of
the double pin Yvonne g6 really nice so
yeah the porn couldn't be taken but what
should like do in the game he played the
move Bishop e6 this is correct and here
d700 straight no idols also the only
move that yeah keeps keep something keep
something going d7 and now rook b6 this
is a possible choice the most precise
move probably was I think g82 yeah ugh
just exactly where I have to turn the
page in my note and Yahoo g8 probably
wants the strongest move him keeping
this covered and potentially allowing to
go go to the seventh pawn if the right
group decides to move away from the
earth father this is probably roughly
equal something like here group b six
books is seven I hope before me
potentially playing here it's probably
going to end in a draw this is what what
the computer is giving King f7 takes
takes okay 5j and here there is no way
forward at the end this is also an idea
[Music]
like moving this pawn
[Music]
hoochie 8 certainly certainly makes
sense other loop p6 also doesn't look
that bad it just feels that here white
can maybe keep a little something in the
game Luke c7 was played instead and
probably ruka 8 is a little bit more
dangerous it forces the trade yeah and
now there's also this red so would be 8
is the only move Bishop c6 Luke g8 and
rooks e1 white will probably win both
palms and it probably will end like this
Luke c5 III 3557 push where three king g
eight rupees is the line that at the end
i got when i drop this a little bit and
here white has of course chances to win
with his beep on might still end in a
draw but wives winning chances are very
good instead he played hook c7 by the
way this is extremely difficult to
assess especially in a situation where
you don't have lots of time because all
lines look kind of similar and to work
out the differences is extremely
difficult and rupees free is probably
not so good now rook g8 is a bad sorry
King g8 is a better choice better get
them get the King involved and here it's
difficult to see how wide is go to do
something note that currently in this
doesn't lead to anything bishop is on
that square yeah white can of course try
am Bishop a four for example group t6
yeah something like that like still as
pretty decent drawing chance
hoochie a king g8 is probably the best
this was played and hear what had an
opportunity to get a much better ending
may be a winning ending I'm not one
hundred percent sure this was played and
this doesn't help at all but luke t one
was a good idea the idea is actually to
play will create and we try to win the
peace at the end here um then the best
continuation was what would have been at
this one there should be seven King h7
rook t6 pushing in five looks eight and
now look cakes cakes rupee seven rupee
seven bishops 837 which is a six Luke
c5e for this position I'm not one
hundred percent sure but reasonably sure
that white should win here um I tried to
look that up and in books but I didn't
get elected this is this kind of
situation with the upon I think why this
very easily coming up here or here and I
think probably the e porn doesn't mean
all that much and with just without the
upon white would win going to f8 and
attacking g7 as the thing probably wide
wings in in any case he had to try Luke
the one here in this position after
Bishop d7 looked III all of a sudden
this formerly seven was yeah was
basically gone white rice Bishop before
deform looks eight and ten taken on the
seven yeah now look f8 was played and
this was already this was killing
troublesome for one
you should just take here a bit
surprising that he didn't do that after
look c5 Bishop here which is f 556 and
single book to you one that was my life
this is probably still going to be a
drawers and think there's much to be
done with the pawn on e5 many weaknesses
or mayor pins going on yeah in the gala
this is not that clear if it ended the
draw probably it is but the other other
line was a bit clearer rupee eight books
yet instead of course also possible LG
five rupee five route c7 and the Lucas
stands behind the pawn probably still
not enough to do all that much King as
to King was coming up the problem is
that still white pieces are fairly
active so the a bishop g6 after Bishop
g6 it is a draw I mean black has to do
something else but it's probably
difficult to do something really
substantial king at 6i guess is the best
is the best try something like that
white will just probably stay play for h
form thing is the movie for always gets
answered by King c3m I think the
likelihood of a draw is still relatively
high but black of course can try and
should try this is an immediate roll
take stakes yeah and now will be six and
black king has to go back otherwise he's
in yummy does this looks entirely wrong
threatening g4 so it's a yeah something
like that is happening so black has to
go back and hear ya wipes king is
blocking this and
this is a very own 6-ranked made a
couple of more moves and agreed to draw
yeah I think a good fighting game
absolutely i think the opening part of
this game if we go back was extremely
interesting here black probably should
not grab the pawn and play Bishop a six
instead but it is very remarkable how
yeah how both play at handle this like
giving up this pawn and then playing
cream III is really extremely strong now
we've seen that this gives white very
good play and after the trade like was
also under pressure I think that still
instead of 94 I think keeping more
pressure with this book a two or
something like that what's more
interesting not not trading trading so
much I think one white actually maybe
maybe I'm not I cannot really tell it
may be why did not anticipate 96 when he
when he opted for this whole sequence
and here again there was some chances
for wide with the deep porn but um like
um is precise the draw is probably quite
a logical result yeah I hope you would
like the coverage of this game I think
it was a really interesting name thanks
for watching